Marjorie Taylor green after being
heckled out of New York City on the day
of Donald Trump's arrest
likened Trump to Nelson Mandela and
Jesus as she fled her own protest in an
SUV president Trump is joining some of
the most incredible people in history
being arrested today Nelson Mandela was
arrested served time in prison Jesus
Jesus was arrested and murdered by the
Roman government there have been many
people throughout history that have been
arrested and persecuted by radical
corrupt governments and it's beginning
today in New York City
um and I just can't believe it's
happening but I'll always support him
he's done nothing wrong truly one of the
worst people currently in Congress